we didn't have an obr report okay and
that's basically where we get an
independent take from this institution
the office budget responsibility of just
what the impact is going to be on the
economy as well because you know they
will be able to give us a sense of how
much growth is expected from this we
didn't get that what we did get from the
treasury though are some broad costings
now there's something called the
scorecard it's a kind of measure of just
how much each of the different policies
is expected to cost and either if it's
something that's going out of the
treasury it's a negative territory so
those bars will be below the zero line
if it's something that's coming out if
it's basically something that's coming
back in so they're raising money the
lines are in positive territory and what
we can probably tell here these bars are
very negative indeed there is lots of
spending lots of money leaving the
treasury mostly in foregone taxes and
just see see where it's come so for
instance well let's go over to the kind
of the end of the forecast Horizon as
they call it so 2026-27 the whole thing
is coming to about 45 billion pounds
that is a lot of money it's a lot of
money here you know it's more than we
you normally get in in a typical budget
it's going back to that point it's not a
mini budget probably the biggest chunk
of that is actually I think more or less
the biggest chunk was corporation tax so
reversing the corporation tax uh rise uh
that was planned by Russia sunac but the
the reversal of uh the next rise is
about the same cost you're talking about
kind of getting on for 20 billion for
each of those these are enormous sums
they are really enormous sums and it
just underlines
that that planning essentially kind of
permanent uh tax cuts here the one thing
I wanted to add on to this because it's
you probably could have been asking
yourself where has this come given it's
the most expensive thing of all is the
energy price guarantee and that money
for businesses actually you need to add
that on to the bottom of where we are
now and that that bar there you can see
how it's changed everything the
complexion to everything else because it
makes this bar the Year we're in right
now bigger in terms of spending than any
other year but that's only for six
months so you can expect that
potentially to be even bigger well it
almost certainly will be even bigger
it's just an extraordinary amount of
money coming out of the treasury going
out there into the public but not being
financed by spending cuts or tax Rises
being financed by borrowing and that is
really really striking next thing really
I want to show you is just what the
Market's doing because obviously if
we're doing all of this extra borrowing
and look at it you can see that's a lot
of extra money we need to borrow
hundreds of billions over the course of
the future years then we need to raise
it somewhere someone needs to lend us
that money that is kind of how it works
and so you need to go out there oh
actually sorry there's one thing before
we get to that I'm going to show you the
market thing a sec because this is just
taking the big picture and looking at
how much in the way of tax cuts we've
seen here compared with other previous
budgets so the higher these bars are the
more of a tax cutting budget you're
talking about so there you can see Ken
Clark 1996 that was after his period of
kind of austerity there here you can see
Lawson a few Lawson budgets Jeffrey
Howard Dennis Healey Jeffrey Howell 1982
Lawson 1988 held up by a lot of people
within the conservative party as one of
the greatest this budgets ever a big tax
cutting budget looks other people would
disagree they'd say that that caused a
boom in the early 90s there's Anthony
Barber 1972 the baba boom budget again
pretty notorious that did not end well
and here is quasi-quarten so that is one
of the biggest tax cutting budgets in
history the biggest we've had in 50
years and as I was saying a moment ago
has there been some Market reaction well
have a look this is just showing you
government bond yields which is the rate
at which we are having to borrow this
money so we're borrowing an extra x
billion pounds and the x is a big number
and we are having to pay higher and
higher rates on that borrowing so it
means it's more expensive so it means
the debt interest costs are going to be
even more in future that's just what
happens when you become a high debt
economy and we certainly are becoming
more of a high debt economy you have to
spend pay more for that and final thing
to Just note is what's happening in
currency markets now this is the pound
against the dollar it's just one of the
many exchange rates against Sterling and
this is literally just the story of the
day so the chance I was I was showing
you a second ago was looking back many
years this is just looking back today so
that's last night here's the morning and
you can see for most of the morning
the pound was kind of round about the
level of about
1.12 against uh against the dollar well
when quasi-quarting stood up it was
about 1.12
by the time the markets have begun to
react it was down to about 111 and last
time I looked I need to update those
charts but last time I looked uh it was
down below 1 11 so getting for 110 in a
bit
that's quite worrying I think that's the
kind of thing the treasury would be
worried about but we have to wait and
see